a three-hour visit with
major geopolitical significance the
three u.s senators touching down in
taiwan
and promising to give the island 750 000
covert 19 vaccines a show of support and
gratitude to taiwan
for sending supplies to the u.s during
the peak of its own outbreak in 2020
we are here as friends because we know
that taiwan
is experiencing a challenging time right
now which is why it was especially
important for the three of us to be here
in a bipartisan way
friends come to each other's aid
taiwan was initially one of the
pandemics success stories
last year it went more than eight months
without any domestic
transmission but it's recently had a
surge of infections
recording most of its more than two
hundred and twenty deaths in the past
month
we are very thankful to the biden
administration for extending a helping
hand and putting taiwan in the first
group of countries to receive the
vaccines shared by the u.s
these vaccines are a lifesaver to taiwan
we will not forget your help
fewer than three percent of the island's
23 million people
have been vaccinated this week more than
one million doses were donated by japan
taiwan has signed contracts for doses
from astrazeneca and moderna
and it's accused china of interfering in
potential deals to secure vaccines from
pfizer
some though blame inefficiencies by the
taiwanese authorities
and china says taiwan's governing party
is preventing it from sending doses of
its own vaccines
chinese-made medical products are banned
under taiwanese law
the authorities have obstructed the
mainland from sending vaccines to taiwan
in every possible way and even falsely
claimed
that the mainland has hindered its
procurement of vaccines for their own
political interest
the authorities continue to engage in
political manipulation
china's governing communist party views
the island as a part of its territory
and has vowed to one day seize it by
force if necessary
their complex relationship has seen
taiwan effectively locked out of
membership
of the world health organization the
united states is donating vaccines to
multiple places around the world as
china is
and that's just part of the competition
between the united states and china
to maintain relationships worldwide and
that would include
taiwan washington remains taiwan's
biggest ally
senators promising the island that it
will not face the pandemic alone
alexi o'brien al jazeera